it is so juicy so sweet this is my kind
of meat
hi my name is frank and i'm a tasty
producer and today we are going to make
my favorite dish cha soup charsu is
honey roasted barbecue pork in cantonese
it is pronounced tasu
it translates to pork roast which is a
traditional chinese method of cooking
this dish in chinese cuisine all the
ingredients serve a purpose ginger
garlic and five spice gets rid of the
pork smell it also gives it so much more
flavor touching wine is rice wine and
adds another depth of flavor and sesame
oil makes everything smell so much
better hoisin sauce is seafood sauce and
it adds some umami and sweetness to it
and do not forget the red bean curd
gives chatsu the iconic red color and
flavor no worries it is not spicy these
ingredients are common in many asian
dishes so it's definitely worth getting
them and you can probably find them at
the asian aisle or at your local chinese
supermarket trustee is so common in
cantonese restaurants that it is the
standard that locals use to compare
which restaurant is better
since recipes can vary from restaurant
to restaurant if yours is different from
mine that's totally fine chatsu is every
chinese kid on a blog's favorite dish
whenever my parents head out to
chinatown they will always bring back
our favorite standard order a pound of
thinly sliced half skinny half fat
chatsu my favorite parts are definitely
the fatty pieces and the charred burnt
edges there's just so much flavor and
it's so delicious sometimes hot soup is
served with rice and vegetables or you
can order the protein to go and add it
to your family dinner next time where
you're about to order chinese takeout
instead of ordering that sweet and sour
report give charizard a try you might
just love it
my mom would be so proud
oh yes
[Music]
you